great burritos okay apologies for
absence
don't be mr. time do you have copies in
the minutes of the third April guys are
pretty happy for those declarations of
interest matters referred to the
executive and the corpsman rather writes
please - straight on to item 6 1 - cloud
service contract award Simon you've just
noticed um we have councillor sa Smith
rather than SP Smith this time it's
domain just interesting nobody aged at
least some suggestions I'm sure I can
pass over to know me in just just a
moment but just very briefly as an
introduction we know that we've we've
had a variety of our IT problems over
time and of course IT never stands still
and the capabilities are increasing all
the time we're now at a stage where we
feel it is appropriate to move to a
cloud-based system for our revenue and
benefits contract it might appeared on
the surface that is not a cheap contract
and this this contract might cost us a
little bit more I think there's a couple
of things to bear in mind if we were to
go out to the marketplace there might be
a few thousand pounds to be saved on the
the annual cost but it doesn't factor in
the cost of transferring to another
service provider the retraining the the
the updating of equipment and so on
which would which would undoubtedly be
near hundred
so a fully managed service from capita
does seem like the way forward but a
pretty dim proportion we actually handle
them approximately 76 million pounds
most people just have the council tax
figure of the the main council budget of
about 10 million pounds in their in
their mind but really with all the
different things that we handle business
rates and so on 76 million pounds is the
figure and the cost of this contract
represents 0.2% of that so I think that
helps put it in proportion but also in
terms of future planning on 6.2 you do
see that this is a fixed price contract
for five years so that will help us with
our with our budget planning being
inflation-proof to an extent now pass
over to no man yes I said and the
decision that you're being asked to
agree tonight is to award a five-year
contracts to have the business services
the one revenue benefits cloud service
which does encompass the academy
software which is the main piece of
software we use for processing all of
our council tax and business rates and
Housing Benefit services it's been
you're being asked to approve this with
an immediate start date for that reason
we've asked that it's not subject to
callin the reason for that is that in
order to implement this system the head
of the next financial year we will have
to immediately start a transition phase
in order that we can secure the slot
with the capital with the aim of the
intentional and going live in early
autumn so September 7 time so if we are
not able to procure the contract
immediately we will put in jeopardy nap
slot and to go live in September
we are into the annual bidding process
again into the subsequent financial year
so so that's the reason it's we've asked
for it not to be subject to call in
tonight just a little bit more context
to what's in the report so there's three
main advantages of procuring or going
into this new this news contracting
capita so the first we've mentioned
already is it will be cloud compatible
and that means that we can migrate into
capitis cloud service and that will
reduce our reliance on our own internal
host system and action secured
increasingly only reliability of
residents of the system so some of the
IT issues that we face over the past few
months should become less once we are
transitioned into this system because
their identity of the cloud would be all
the data and secondly it will just give
us more contractual certainty around the
terms and conditions who are pricing
around us so the existing contracts been
in place for a month or 20 years now and
over that time it's obviously changed
and things been added and you know
changed over that period of time so this
will give us the certainty of water is
we're buying and the ability to hold
capita to account it said they don't
deliver the same set for any reason so
in the second chapter of certainty and
thirdly yes we'll provide a fully
managed service so that will reduce the
reliance on our own internal offices to
help manage the system so particularly
IT but also some of the recommends
offices that help keep the system that
he running at the moment it will reduce
the reliance on them to do that work and
again naturally increase the
reliance and reliability of of
assistance so I think the rest of their
reports hopefully so quite
self-explanatory Stephanie let's go any
further questions I'm happy to try and
answer though but I would recommend that
this is the best way best way forward
for counsel in terms of ensuring that
we've got that there was an in-service
for our residents
Thank You chairman having passed this
over to Simon and I totally support this
where some benefits have been struggling
for a while now I'm a computer from the
IT situation Anna Simon said it's a very
much a money-making department within
the council and I totally support it and
I think you know all credit goes to the
staff and I owe me for what I've had to
put up with in the last few years we
have to be tough out there and I have
been down to read some benefits and
thank them for all their support and yes
I do support it thank you
yeah I concur with what Cheryl said with
regards to supporting the migration to
the cloud and and going to the new
system
I wouldn't say reservation but have we
got to get out falls within the five
years to allow us to go to another data
provider once we're in the cloud that's
my first question
so we're in line with the new earth I
can't remember the edges service new
[Music]
company name but
yeah well there isn't any break for was
provision within the five years so we
will be too touchy back to the five-year
period and I would say that the
discussion of worthy and if we were to
look at it from the other the other eye
or even with our existing contractual
arrangements where in theory we could
exit the contracts for the end of any
particular year as I've alluded to in
the report the complexities around
actually migrating to a different system
the extensive procurement process would
have to go through plus all of the
migration and transition of the data
retraining I wasn't talking about today
I wasn't talking about migrating to a
new system once you're in the cloud we
can actually move the whole lot of stock
and barrel from that player to another
cloud which is supported by another
vendor okay so I think that in the case
of this have to have made its basically
clear and we have asked this question
that they're not willing to post their
system in any cloud other than their own
their own cloud so unfortunate well
unfortunately unfortunately they they
take the risk or bath we think lab has
to be hosted within their own coding
system and they're not willing to
understand enough I think I think from
their perspective they want to see
sister or ceases systems that are
running in decline by different
authorities in the same sort of
environment so that gives them the
opportunity to manage the system in a
consistent in a consistent way so I
think that's probably what thinking the
thinking is okay well thank you very
much Jim it's just a couple of questions
one is in regards to I was quite
surprised to hear a figure of 76 million
that passes through our plumbing to the
penny but it's there yeah I mean
sorry chunk there is never any mention
ever about that amount that is actually
us facilitating that amount of cow Moos
system the other thing that actually
interested me was how many staff will
this now free up because I was obviously
looking at the savings cycling's the
extra cost which is thirty thirty
thousand pounds over the top of the
present system but if this is freeing up
staff who are otherwise engaged in
keeping the previous system going and
loss of time and all the rest of it how
many staff all that now free are either
fun it's not going to be freeing up any
stuff yeah I think I understood the
question okay
the question was we were talking about
the simple fact that a lot of the staff
were engaged in remedial work because
the the the system wasn't working well I
think the point I was trying to make is
that people are having to maintain the
system and sort of run processes in
their backgrounds it's not so much to do
in the IT issues per se it's just in
order to run the system as it currently
stands we have to run some of the
processes ourselves so yeah one one
person in the IT department spends some
of this time doing that work I mean it's
not it's not a full-time equivalent role
in doing that but also within the
revenues benefits team there's a couple
of members of staff that do have to
spend a portion of their time each week
doing some of these background processes
which will now be taken on by capita so
we it's difficult for us to quantify
exactly and it probably won't be exactly
a full-time included a post that would
be freed up or the efficiency saving
that would be made but it will be a
chunk of two or three members of staff's
time that will be freed up to do our
protocol or restore to get to it yes
I can get on with a dye job yeah and I
think that we can we will be taking
those those savings in creating a more
efficient delivery of this revenue and
benefits system analysis now he was
saying we're looking at getting started
by September time so within that startup
period if we are seeing that there are
people sitting around not doing a lot
then that will take advantage of that
one revenues of benefits cloud service
income seeing the provision of academy
software which is required to carry out
appearances call revenues and benefits
services with immediate staff ain't
nobody happy that very second item is to
agree the decision is not subject to
coverage due to the immediate business
need to start with the sorry and
transition phase in summer 2019 in order
to migrate the system in September 2019
ahead of the start of the annual big
billing process for 2021 if the decision
is delayed it's unlikely that the
software could be migrating to the cloud
head of the 2021 financial year nobody's
happy with that
item seven and in contract so we're
required to do this every every so often
the the actual process has gone through
the due process a human process it's
quite detailed it's quite long windy but
without wanting to to make light of it
it was a one-horse race and only Lloyds
Bank submitted an application to take on
the contract they are the people and we
we bank with currently it's an initial
contract of five years but could be
seven years so we're not we're not
likely to go go go through this again
for quite some time
we're not unhappy with the service that
were being provided with at the moment
however the cost is likely to go up the
car that the exact cost can't be
determined because an amount of it is
based on the number of transactions that
we we take but again - just to give you
a an idea it's estimated that the the
cost of the contract is 0.025 percent of
the accounts ons money handling
requirements and we mustn't forget that
actually there are many tens of
thousands of people of residents and
businesses that we serve through this
bank account so it's it is very
important question it seems we've only
had one person come back to us through
this is there any reason why it just
did you know why do you know I suppose
if you guys watch what so do we Tracy
yeah it's a difficult one to know I
think when we did it previously a couple
years ago we had two that were
interested so it wasn't this
particularly nice market that either
I think the song banks that obviously
may be more geared up doing directing
back in carotenoids is one of those and
it may be that fact that they're the
incumbent makes it more attractive to
them and potentially yes other banks
it's not such an attractive sort of
contract for them to bid for two-bit
teabagging without doing sort of wider
market wise it's difficult to know
exactly why but as I say we only had two
last time Android's was successful then
so I wasn't entirely unexpected one
night a month one to breathe the warm up
a new five-year contract for lots of
District Council banking services to
Lloyds Bank from August the 1st 2019
item 8 so we're looking at this at the
end of last year so yeah I'd say it's
old news but it's how we performed last
year and I think that you can review the
report that's in front of you and say we
had a very good year it was a
challenging budget to set on that time
ago and we were very concerned about the
environment in which we were going to
have to be operating but quite clearly
through the efficient administration of
this council by the hard work and
dedication of our staff we ran a very
good yeah
and within that year we've also been
able
the main provision for the future by
investing and putting money aside in our
strategic planning for the district so
I'm very pleased to have a part in
presenting this to you but as usual for
the detail Anderson and me and yes this
is the provisional out turn position or
at the 1819 financial year and it's
obviously still subject to and it's then
audited auditing the accounts so it's
possible that could still be slight
changes that go through if there was
anything that people up on but this is
our best estimate of what the year-end
position was for the council as
council's miss Sedley overall underlying
variance is just under seven hundred
thousand pounds which is pretty much in
line with what we've been forecasting
during the year and as such at 43 we
already lost executive to improve the
transfer of six hundred thousand pounds
of that under spent into the local
development fund reserve so that all the
action bringing the total and unspent
down to about seventy thousand pounds so
there's obviously I don't I was
simplifying obviously there's a lot of
different and budget movements within
that position a lot of different unders
and overs but really the core thing
driving the under spent for the year was
spent on salaries which was six hundred
and thirty eight thousand pounds at the
end of the year and that was an
exceptional exceptional year and driven
in part and by just the unexpected sort
of number of vacancies we had which was
slightly outside of our control we just
had a number of
people resign or move on for temporaries
in which which did give rise to a
significant salaries under spend I would
say that we're not anticipating that
position to people to continue into the
1920 financial year given that we are
now Amelia for establishment again so it
was a particularly unusual year that
drives up during the underspend position
I just like strong attention to the fact
that obviously there is a number of
budgets which we've asked to carry
forward into reserves for specific
reasons and they are mainly for specific
projects or particular grants that we
want we've got specific reasons to use
in 1920 and also today the capital
position which again there is a very
significant chunk of the capital budget
which wasn't spent in 1819 so we are
asking to go for 1.4 million within
large significant amount of days due to
the air quality which we've been awarded
which was a significant one of the month
money which is planned to be spent in
1920 so again I wouldn't anticipate that
we would have that level of is going
going toward interview GS but I
something we'll be paying particular
Island during 1920 to ensure the capital
budgets are achievable and up and are
delivered so that's probably all I would
say in terms of the quality link Turkey
and as a report getting happy to take
questions if anyone's got them but there
are obviously a number of
recommendations that the effective is
asked to approve which are listed on
there on the front of the report
questions
we have a number of recommendations on
8.1 are actually 10 recommendations
there and do you want to take them as a
whole take them as a whole yeah you want
we move out individually
we've just happy to accept as per the
problem is the place-based sequence
thank you yeah this has been receiving
very very well and the reason is going
over three years is so that we can make
four years of any grants that are
available it's just very good and this I
haven't said the other day so if there
keeps on giving people may end up
straight about the reform I hope it's
self-explanatory so these features six
and half spending the 650 thousand
allocation cattle on occasion as I said
I'm just trying to I guess I said
however a reasonable time period where
we feel that we can seek match funding
to enjoy those as far as possible
and we've tried to create a system
whereby we've got identified the areas
that have the greatest need all those
are the greatest potential it is a great
item owner and a great project if any
member of the public were to read the
report that we've got in front of us
though that they're not going to get
excited about it but nevertheless when
we've been out and we've talked to
people about what we're planning
they have got excited so I do feel that
on a regular basis we need to ensure
that through our communications team and
through our officers we are we are
telling people on each occasion what
we're planning what we're doing what
we've done so that they can see the
scale of investment we're putting in
right across the district in every
single ward thank you Mike obviously
welcome this report and the work that
we're doing in our district for the
young people
my only concern is in terms of Ashington
rec and the lack of investment there I
have been approached by a number of
residents with very keen to escape all
the park in the recreation ground that's
a project that's been discussed for a
number of years now in fact there's
actually a local work and go set up by
residents which I think device so it's
ashli rec will be a fantastic location
first gave the park just not to be
considered that's okay I know that
planning permission was sought this once
before and the funding was provided all
but something I don't know why he didn't
go ahead but do something we could pick
up thank you yeah well thank you yeah I
think one of the nice things is actually
to see one of the high locality school
places Bedford close this claim up so
many times when we were out visiting
residents it was a forgotten play area
as far as I'm concerned and I think
they're going to be absolutely delighted
to actually see something happening over
there and you know it'd be nice to be
able to go around and say to people what
we've achieved what we said we were
trying to do George yeah I like the
report and I think we've gone a long way
with it
I think we could take that extra
distance where we cadetship for those
charities within the in the district who
have got public land which is open to
the public and they've got play
equipment they can actually benefit from
this grant now the background all the
twos and from the formula to actually
work it out with it how we can do it is
something which I would like to put
forward to the portfolio builder yeah
yeah just an additional question so will
we be looking at adult gym equipment
outdoor as well as doing things in the
play space since owners I think great
way coping is having some regard to the
not winning a grant or not the grantor
he said funding here just drink yeah and
I think they should have priority I
didn't say that they've been out yet I'm
just saying it could actually extend
over for those charitable organization
who have popped play areas who it's open
to the public and that could actually
benefit from that I do have concerns
there are other funding means for them
and this is a weakness we talked about
before but it's something I feel that we
should put once a district council place
basis first but yeah we can look into
that I suggest that to you Chet yes it's
not really relevant now
how about with anything further that may
come after things discuss your Christmas
special it's not really questionable
German it's it's not a statement really
and don't I talk Mike said about
Scotland parks etc the one in Riley
using years ago basically fell apart if
I'm honest and some of the children came
up to us as counselors and said we want
a new scapel park but we said there's no
money you help us and we'll help you so
you give us some suggestions you come up
with some ideas you come up with ways of
raising money and we'll see what we can
do that's capable parking Riley has been
funded by mesh funding from grants but
also a suggestion of all the input from
these children who use it and they do
protect that staple park so going
forward if people are wanting stable
parks in their areas that may be well
that's a good suggestion so to actually
put so so then because I mean NEVER
doing things like shopping packing in in
in the supermarkets and you know
and they didn't know you know you say
Gracie wants money you know that's
that's worth getting involved with with
them you know and let them design it and
they actually look after that scalable
part there's that they own it they do
own it and there's you know there's
rarely any problems over there with it
being perforated or anything about that
because they own it so this is what I
shouldn't have terrain so there's
already a working group that's been
formed looking at the skatepark without
knowing about this resources you made
available and I've asked me to join
their working group
have to do so I just want to not then be
providing a resource there but to be
putting it else purpose of people
potentially Emmental just feels about
we're putting it somewhere the residents
aren't asking for it and yet two miles
down the road the residents are asked
before it and we know further I know
this was something that you actually
bought up a couple of years back the BMX
park in Brantford
is there any measure and financial help
that we can look at in regards to
resurrecting and bringing that back into
some state because I'm looking at all
the various issues we have locally where
maybe it would be a good place for
youngsters to knock off their skeet that
their their steam rather than doing the
anti-social behavior things use a
natural fact I think one of the first
EMF traps in the country he did look and
we came very close to getting somebody
to take it on and sponsor it but perhaps
the portfolio pick up on that and do
some exploring on that it's one just
observation with wiping the better
issues with one of the little parks
there with not accurate information
gladly say can we just step back through
information especially as bishops house
councilors going out to push this same
insightful movie start working on it
needs to be around that day I understand
what happened it's winding things birth
like details on this amazing our
officers will pick up okay we have three
recommendations on page nine point one
the allocated 2019-20 capital budget for
a space improvements of 658 males and
bound to be spent I set out in appendix
2 of this report and supplement 2018-19
Council budget carry forward and
external contributions that we have you
that varied but they also authority be
delegated to the assistant director of
place and environment in consultation
with the portfolio hold refer
environment to a wall contracts with the
delivery of the plate space Improvement
Program
we're happy to commemorate and that the
authority be delegated to the assistant
director and planner place and
environment the consultation with the
portfolio is required to seek and secure
appropriate much funding to assist the
delivery of place-based improvement
program and a very very good thing is
the last item